[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there is this big Global industry
devoted to taking waste from a generally
developed countries and shipping it to
poorer countries many of them in
Southeast Asia
[Music]
environmentalists have come up with a
term to describe this phenomenon and
what they call it is waste colonialism
the idea that rich countries are dumping
their problems literally in some cases
on to poor countries and and letting
poorer countries deal with the waste
created in the rich world so this is a
milk
I went to Thailand hoping to see some of
that process and the problems it's
causing firsthand
you know I've been looking at the data
and that numbers we've realized that a
tremendous amount of uh waste are being
well I don't want to use the word import
inside when these were dump being dumped
into our country
I know before I got involved in this
research what I thought about recycling
was wildly out of step with the
realities of the industry
I can also live here right oh I see I I
come here and I put it over in the house
and inside the house has a strong smell
of the chemistry
they can put up many many plans and they
were planning for one but they told us
that there will be 13 more coming
Thailand is not the global dumpster we
are not an international bin you know so
if you don't have anywhere to put your
rubbish please don't put it in Thailand
in 2021 Thailand received about 158 000
tons of imported plastic waste from
overseas so that is a hell of a lot of
material it obviously needs to be
processed it needs to be recycled not
all of it can be and it may also cause
externalities like pollution like noise
like
fumes that bother local residents so
while we've all been raised to think of
recycling as this kind of clean and
virtuous business this perfect circle
actually there are big problems with the
process
and the and so the factory is right here
where would the fumes come from from
this side from from this hole and this
whole
so for this story one of the people I
spoke to was a man named venue jaraman
Kong venue is an accountant he has a
house in the Bangkok suburbs and a
couple of years ago he found out that a
property next to his house which had
previously been used as a sort of
storage yard was being turned into a
recycling plant
the whole area of this covered in Smoke
yes and that's why you have this this
man so after this plant got going uh
vinyu noticed that uh there were really
noxious fumes coming into his home you
cannot breathe you have a headache
doctor said I need to move my son out of
here
he told me that he was having trouble
breathing getting headaches he was
experiencing skin irritation he started
finding dead pigeons on his front lawn
which as you can imagine is pretty
alarming
and it appears based on some scientists
I spoke to have looked at this issue
that these were fumes from hydrocarbon
exposure that plastic was being melted
down which of course creates fumes that
if they're not properly filtered and
vented can be really damaging to people
and Wildlife and so that's what venue
was experiencing in his home so if this
is killing pigeons it's pretty bad yes
it's going to kill my family too
so I I have to let it go
and leave this house yes leave the house
[Music]
when I think of a recycling plant
certainly before I did this research you
think of something clean and inoffensive
you know part of this circular economy
that we're all told is is such a
wonderful thing but the reality is a
little Messier recycling plants can be
quite dirty and dangerous places they
can throw off serious pollution
chemicals that include things like
dioxin which have been associated with
increased risk of cancer
[Music]
so we're heading out of Bangkok now to
chonburi Province and we're going to
visit a community where there's been a
lot of opposition to plastic recycling
and Manufacturing facilities
the company do not keep you know follow
the rule follow the writing sometimes
they just burn it plastic you know
whenever they want they put this under
the ground pollute the water you know
they run it all the time making noises
you know people cannot
stay on that
most of the people affected by recycling
plants and this is true all over the
world
tend to be poor tend to be vulnerable
people who don't have a lot of recourse
to the legal system or otherwise
we organize three protests actually you
know each one get bigger and bigger the
last one was about a year and a half ago
and we got together right around 700
people right in front of the factory the
plan
we protest we have put up the side but
at the end it's just another activity
that we did but they would get any
response back
foreign
there's a simple reason why there is
such a huge demand for recycling
globally and and that is that we all
consume an incredible amount of plastic
in particular plastic consumption has
skyrocketed all over the world but
countries like the US like Japan like
the UK don't have the domestic capacity
to recycle all that plastic in fact they
have nowhere near the domestic capacity
they would need so the only way to deal
with it if you don't want to just throw
it into landfill is to send it overseas
to stuff it into shipping containers and
send it to poorer countries where that
infrastructure does exist so that's what
we've seen over the last five or six
years in Southeast Asia is a big
increase in long-haul recycling
shipments largely from the rich world
[Music]
we detected a container full of
so-called plastic scraps but uh you know
he opened it up it's not scratched
inside it's all plastic waste so just
recently yeah a couple of months ago so
so we uh kindly throw it back to the US
I've asked our Pollution Control
Department to coordinate very closely
with all the other agencies concerned
and put well put our fists down on it of
course we cannot just say we're going to
stop from 100 to zero overnight it has
to be a gradual change and uh you know
there's differences between plastic
scraps and plastic waste and
unfortunately the plastic waste are
being disguised as plastic scraps on
paper and in the past I think some
people have used it as a loophole to to
bring those waste into Thailand
the Thai government has for a few years
now been moving toward a ban on foreign
plastic waste import but as I learned
from the environment Minister and from
others I've spoken to that's much easier
said than done
recycling is a big industry there are in
Thailand Malaysia Indonesia large and
profitable companies that depend on
among other things plastic waste imports
from overseas and so they've been a
source of opposition to these measures
do you think the government will really
ban
plastic Imports effectively
from time to time I don't believe in
anything
I believe in when it happened or
pronounced as a law when some something
hurt the economy something hurt the
people workers or whatever
that plan will be delayed we need a lot
of us the plastic single use plastic and
recycle plastic law
foreign
over the last several years Malaysia
Indonesia Thailand those countries have
cracked down to varying extents on waste
Imports and what's going to happen next
I think it's very fair to say is these
flows of waste will find their ways to
other countries and perhaps to countries
that are much poorer Myanmar is one that
gets talked about a lot there are
countries in Africa that are being
talked about a lot as potential
destinations and these are places even
less able to cope with these inflows
than a Thailand or in Indonesia is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]